pas
[Musique]
ce noël venez découvrir l'histoire du
premier noël
d'un point de vue totalement nouveau ce
sont nos matchs dash 8
de l'autre côté déborah est ce que ça va
dans ta tête
regardons ça vaut combien de co2 km
cette année ces animaux héroïque vont
devoir sauver noël
le nouveau roi tant chez le roi hérode
me jette quelque chose n'a rien peut
soit être pour toi la sauver avec une
petite diversion juste et avec finesse
[Musique]
pour aller jusqu'à mes amis vous devrez
me passer sur le corps
[Musique]
et ruth on est en bas de gamme cible
[Applaudissements]
la réception n'était pas très soignée
mais tu te débrouilles à gauche l'étoile
de noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]